bonsoir jérôme marty merci gère avec
nous sur arte france pour faire un point
justement sur ces prédictions on entend
beaucoup de choses de la part des
scientifiques on est un petit peu dans
le flou puisque personne ne peut
véritablement prédire ce qui va se
passer
vous êtes d'accord avec le fait que
l'épidémie pourrait s'aggraver encore
dans les mois qui viennent et est
retombé pour pour mois de janvier
malheureusement elle pourrait oui alors
il n'y a pas de certitudes vous savez il
faut il faut juste être factuel il faut
regarder ce qui se passe à la journée et
puis se retourner sur ce qui s'est passé
14 jours avant les voir s'il ya oui ou
non une progression est tout ce que l'on
peut dire c'est que de 14 jours en 14
jours il ya une progression qui est tout
à fait rire régulière voire
exponentielle et que cela reproduit en
gros ce qui s'est passé en floride qui
nous a précédés de quelques semaines
avec une population jeune qui a été
touchée après les spring break
et puis des corridors qui sont créés
avec les populations les plus fragiles d
hospitalisation d réanimation et
malheureusement des décès c'est ce qu'on
risque de revivre en france avec un
virus qui globalement partout dans tous
les territoires avec quelques
territoires qu'ils soient en avance par
rapport à d'autres
alors voilà c'est aussi quand on veut
voir ce qui se passe on compare avec nos
voisins européens l'italie semble-t-il
est plus à la vraie comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer que dans certains pays le
virus progresserait davantage
oui ou en tout cas se propagerait plus
vite alors que plus ou moins les mesures
restent les mêmes le port du masque et
le lavage de mains voyez mais nous on a
deux on a deux choses d'une part il ya
eu de la levée du corps est finement
avec légitimement des gens qui sont
relâchés pendant l'été et puis beaucoup
de jeunes avec des quêtes une population
et de fortes interactions sociales qui
sont contaminés puis qui ont ramené
ensuite cette contamination dans leur
territoire
ça c'est la première chose et puis
l'échec des tests vous savez que les
énormément de français seront testés y
compris des gens qui n'ont pas de
symptômes qui sont qui ce qu'ils font
n'est pas juste pour se rassurer des
laboratoires qui sont emboliser des
tests qui au final ne servent plus à
rien parce qu'il ya trop de temps entre
le moment où on demande le test et le
moment où on obtient le résultat ce qui
fait que le toute façon même s'il est
positif
cela ne sert quasi plus rien puisque la
personne qui est testé les plus vectrice
de virus et surtout les gens qu'elle a
contaminé sont déjà devenus contaminante
personnes qui elles mêmes sont déjà
comme devenu contaminantes audois de
personnel en le virus circule et la
maladie se répand et ça peut être que
dans les autres pays ils sont plus
performants sur les tests en moyenne 16
mai une contamination recensés en tout
cas par jour ça veut dire que quelque
part il est devenu incontrôlable
puisqu'on n'a pas réussi à mettre en
place
en tout cas c'est ce qui avait été
promis il ya une semaine une
priorisation ces tests non je crois
qu'on peut pas encore parler d'un
contrôle habilités et fort heureusement
on n'est quand même pas sur des niveaux
que l'on a connu fin mars début avril
mais on peut progressivement y arriver
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
extrêmement vigilant et respecter les
mesures barrières mais cela demande
beaucoup d'explications des explications
claires précises factuels pour qu'elle
soit comprise par la population est
appliquée en fait il faut faire l'
inverse de ce qui a été fait pour
marseille où on a décidé avec sa bru pto
des choses très dures sans trop les
expliquer je crois qu'il faut prendre
les corporations qui sont visés parfois
par des décisions et il faut leur
expliquer très en amont ce qui se passe
avec des chiffres avec des précisions
claire de façon à ce que tout cela soit
compris parce que le virus ait pas de
politique lui le virus avance et tout le
monde doit lutter contre lui quelques
quelle quelle que soit sa profession
qu'elle soit son statut pour pour vous
c'est une bonne mesure ce qui est
appliqué à marseille la fermeture des
bars et des restaurants à partir de
demain soir je peux pas le dire parce
qu'on a on n'a pas réellement si vous
voulez de remonter et de statistiques
précises sur le nombre de personnes qui
ont été contaminées dans les restaurants
dans les bars ou après 22h et c'est ce
que l'on sait c'est qu'évidemment dans
un restaurant on ne porte pas le masque
par essence que si ce restaurant est mal
aérée cela peut créer des problèmes mais
mais aussi aussi que la plupart des
contaminations actuellement se passe
dans la structure familiale parce que
dans la structure familiale
on se sent quelque sorte protéger parce
qu'on ne connaît les gens qui sont avec
vous que ce soit votre famille ou des
amis et on a tendance à se relâcher
enlever le masque pas nécessairement
ouvrir les fenêtres et c'est là que se
font actuellement la plupart des
clusters est-ce que c'est pas là la clé
j'ai remarqué justement de pouvoir
savoir exactement où et quand sont
contaminés les personnes si évidemment
c'est ce que fait d'ailleurs l'allemagne
il vous savez l'allemagne a su définir
quels étaient les lieux à risque et
c'est
c'est lui à risque qu'elle met le paquet
en terme de moyens nous il faut que le
colonel et possibilité de déterminer qui
se contaminent quand et où
et ça on ne peut le faire avec le
travail des équipes de l'assurance
maladie qui font du contact racing ça
fait maintenant quatre mois que le faux
il ya des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de français étaient passés en
quelque sorte de screening qui a été
contact qui a été au contact de
personnes qui sont positifs rogla virus
et donc qui ont aussi rousset personnes
se sont contaminées à partir de là on
peut déterminer les lieux à risque et on
peut agir sur ces lieux il faut des
cônes et une cartographie extrêmement
précises territoire par territoire pour
pouvoir agir et agir plus vite mais ça
me pose encore une fois qu'on les
déteste qu'ils soient faits beaucoup
plus rapidement alors justement les
tests antigénique ont reçu le feu vert
de la haute autorité
expliquez-nous ce que c'est et est-ce
que ça va pouvoir résoudre le problème
des engorgements mais le test un petit
génie qui permet si vous voulez d'avoir
une réponse en 20 minutes 20 minutes à
une demi-heure et la voie actuellement
on va jusqu'à 7 jours 10 jours avant de
donner une réponse à la personne qui cp
tester du fait de la mobilisation des
laboratoires et ça ça permet d'être
beaucoup plus efficace sur la remontée
de filière c'est à dire quand on a
quelqu'un que l'on détecte quelqu'un de
positif on va tout de suite agir sur
cette paire familiale et puis on va tout
de suite lancé une enquête pour savoir
qui est ce qu'il a croisé dans les jours
qui ont précédé et on va les tester ses
propres personnes les mettre à l'abri
les isoler et ça ça casse complètement
la diffusion de l'épidémie dont le test
antigénique permet véritablement d'être
tout à fait efficace malheureusement est
ce qu'on va en avoir assez est ce qu'on
va pouvoir agir notamment sur la
médecine de ville qui est un véritable
réservoir de patients mais on rappelle
que 95 % des patients sont en ville sont
bas à l'hôpital
or là on nous dit que pour l'instant les
tests un petit génie qui ont plutôt être
réservée à l'hôpital
ce qui veut dire qu'on ne va pas pouvoir
faire étudier deux grandes cohortes de
malades et ça risque de poser problème
mais c'est toujours les médecins de
ville qui sont en première ligne mais
pas forcément les premiers sollicités
autre information l'om est-ce dit
craindre un doublement du nombre de
morts dans les prochains mois deux
scientifiques prix nobel de l'économie
disent qu'il faut re confiné du 1er au
20 décembre pour éviter un nombre de
morts justement chez les personnes âgées
avant
elle c'est alarmiste est ce qu'il faut y
prêter attention il faut faire une
rotation au principe de prévisions vous
savez on connaît le principe de
précaution et puis là maintenant
apparaît de plus en plus le principe de
prévisions on s'est tellement
plurifactoriels il ya tellement de
choses qui rentrent en ligne de compte
qu'il est extrêmement difficile de faire
des prévisions
alors évidemment la période de noël est
dangereuse parce que c'est la période où
on se réunit où il ya beaucoup de
croiser de population c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que à cette période-là en
général la gastro entérite qui manie
porter explose parce que les gens se
font la bise se croisent etc
mais mais mais qu'est ce qui va arriver
d'ici là noël à noël vous savez à
l'échelon de serre à l'échelle de cette
maladie c'est très loin
donc c'est très difficile de faire des
projections encore une fois reste au
factuel regardons ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui retourne retournant nous
regardons ce qu'il s'est passé et à
partir de là voyons si oui ou non la
maladie progresse mais regardez à deux
mois trois mois c'est extrêmement
difficile
merci beaucoup géant marty d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france